853 that's going low Magnus you wanted
the black pieces here hello everybody
this is Grandmaster Pepe quena and we
are watching an armagedon game between
Magnus kson and Wesley so at the
Champions chess to finals in Toronto
Canada where Magnus has won the BET and
he'll play with the black pieces and 8
minutes and 53 seconds Wesley will play
with 15 minutes and the white pieces
meaning that Wesley is forced to win
this game in order to win the match on
the country Magnus only needs a draw in
order to win this battle so let's see
what happens in this crazy Armageddon
remember there's no increment until move
61 and we're off Wesley opens with E4
Magnus replying with C5 the Sicilian one
of the most aggressive weapons against
E4 here two main moves Knight to F3 or
Knight to C3 and Wesley goes for the
close Sicilian the main move now is
Knight to C6 simply controlling the D
first square but also E6 D6 A6 or even
G6 are decent tries for black in this
position Magnus going for Knight C6 and
once again many interesting setups now
for white you can go for the faneto with
G3 you can play the Grand Prix attack
with F4 but Wesley plays Knight F3
simply transposing to an anti Sicilian
this is a good order you want to avoid
the bnck of Sicilia Manu goes for E5
controlling D4 the drawback is that of
course now the A2 G8 diagonal is weaker
and that's why Bishop C4 is the
strongest move and Magnus goes for G6
and secondary alternative that he has
employed already against for instance
Yan neomia after D3 Knight G5 was
threatened for instance uh Bishop G7 is
considered to be a mistake since after
Knight G5 Knight H6 is the only move and
then after H4 uh White is better so
that's why black plays first H6 stopping
G5 and the main move is H4 ining H5 but
Wesley plays this humble move with A3
what's the idea behind H3 probably to
free the H2 Square for the Knight Magnus
goes D6 now the C8 Bishop has a light it
can breathe uh some fresher and Knight
H2 from Wesley so well the G4 square is
also tasty for the White Knight in many
variations because you can put pressure
against H6 but but probably the main
idea behind Knight H2 is to push F4 in
the near future right imagine opening
the file the bishop on C4 and an
eventual Rook on F1 could be putting
tremendous pressure against the pawn on
F7 short castle by Wesley so and Magnus
continues developing with Knight to F6
blocking the file and now after F4
probably black is first to take on F4
otherwise F5 could be extremely annoying
for black in D position F4 played by
Wesley so Magnus it takes F4 and now
Wesley completes development by playing
Bishop to F4 Magnus sh castles uh now
and well there are many interesting
moves now for White Knight A3 also Queen
D2 makes a lot of sense in my opinion
because you connect the Rooks and uh you
do that by winning a Tempo another
interesting fact about this position is
that most powerful piece for white is
the bishop on C4 so usually black wants
to take measures against this bishop on
C4 you can do that by playing Knight A5
in order to grab the bishop here or you
can do that by playing Bishop to E6 uh
facing directly this uh Bishop on C4 so
Bishop E6 from Magnus gson and now
Magnus is saying you know what if you
take this bishop on E6 then I will put a
Pawn on E6 of course I will recapture an
E6 and then the D5 square is not going
to be weak anymore so what is Wesley s
thinking in this position I don't know
Knight G5 what what is this move Wesley
saw sacrificing a full piece what did
you drink today Wesley what did you put
in the coffee Knight G5 sacrificing a
piece playing like Mi tal today so
what's the idea after Pawn takes C5
Bishop takes C5 there is a terrible pin
against F6 the bishop on G5 The Rook on
F1 you bring another piece to the file
then black is going to struggle to
protect the Knight on F6 so Magnus cson
playing Knight E5 what's the idea behind
Knight E5 probably just to bring this
Knight back to D7 increasing de
protection of the Knight on F6 Queen F2
now if you want to save this Knight on
F6 you are forced to go Knight to D7
back right this is the only way to
protect that uh Knight on F6 and there
are so many interesting attacking ideas
for white here after Knight D7 guys for
instance I imagine a queen coming to H4
with a check I imagine white doubling
Rooks on the f file right uh but now of
course you know black just simply want
to move the queen away from d8 you know
uh unpinning uh the Knight on F6 so what
to play here with the white p PES Queen
H4 probably is a candidate move Bishop
A6 is just a terrible move because after
Pawn takes C6 The Rook is also now a
defender of the Knight on F6 wow such a
complicated position so after E5 black
could also think about taking with the
pawn and E5 from Wesley so there we go D
takes E5 Magnus doesn't think much and
probably now the idea is to go Knight E4
well Magnus thinking remember there's no
increment and uh of of course uh in time
trouble this could be extremely bad for
Magnus he goes Queen B6 the idea is that
of course uh black is now threatening to
capture on e4 naturally the queen is not
on d8 anymore so I'm wondering what
happens after Queen H4 Knight H5 only
move Queen H4 on the board from Wesley
so he doesn't want to take on F6 he
cannot make a draw in this game and he's
playing like Mi
tal sacrificing everything in this game
even his Jack he has sacrificed pie on
G5 he has sacrificed Pawn on e4 now he's
going to offer the jacket to Magnus cson
for sure in the next move and now G4
once again pinning the Knight on H5
Magnus takes on C4 and Wesley is about
to move but finally he uh he thinks a
little bit more because now he has two
extremely interesting options Wesley now
thinking such a fantastic arm game and
well I would take on C4 not out against
Magnus Calton I would be scared I will
love to get my material back but of
course these guys are geniuses and he
takes an age five wow keep sacrificing
pieces this
guy wow Wesley is considered to be an
extremely solid player but of course he
is a fantastic tactical player he is one
of the best chess players in the world
he actually dominates every face of the
game and taking on H5 is not very good
for black in my opinion now because
after Queen
H5 uh King G8 D takes C4 uh White gets
the material back and of course you also
have some ideas with Knight F6 in this
position and after Bishop D5 now well
you can take on G6 but also Knight F6 is
very interesting now Knight F6 let's
take a look at this option Knight F6
check guys Knight takes F6 and then you
have two possibilities Bishop F6 but I
think Bishop F6 could be dubious in that
position because of G5
closing the H file and after Queen G5
maybe Rook G8 and now uh the G file is
opened and The Rook on G8 is doing a
great job and the King on G1 could be
suffering a lot incredible so after
Knight F6 Knight F6 maybe Rook F6 and
Wesley so goes for Knight F6 check and
after Knight F6 is Rook F6
working chess is so beautiful Rook F6
working because if black takes on F6
with the bishop Pawn takes G6 the king
is forced to take on G6 and the key is
that now white can go Queen H6 check
this forces black to jump to F5 with the
King and then Rook F1 check only move is
King E6 Rook F6 and white takes the
queen on F6
so Wesley what did you drink today Rook
F6 such a beauti full move Bishop F6 now
runs into H takes C6 followed by Queen
to H6 Magnus can think about taking with
the queen as well he's got only two
options because retreating the queen
runs into Pawn takes G6 with mate so he
takes with the queen but of course this
is just a very good position for Wesley
so now Magnus tries to close the H file
with a move G5 trying to create some
counterplay with a rook and G8 but after
Queen G5 let's count pieces guys uh so
Magnus has a queen against a rook and a
bishop and then some pawns as well he
plays Queen F5 and 86 deflection he
takes with a check now and of course the
only sad piece in the board is the A1
Rook if Wesley manages to bring the Rook
to G1 then black is going to suffer a
lot Wesley going for a check now taking
some time now to finish the game he
knows he's got the advantage he knows he
can defeat the Wall well the number one
in the one I was about to say the world
champion but of course you guys know
that the current world champion is
dingler in but the number one in the
wall of course Queen F6 back King H7 and
maybe some King H2 or King F2 if a rook
lands on G1 then Queen H4 would be made
so Rook G1 is threatened that's why
Magnus goes Rook G2 trying to activate
Rook on G2 but Queen H4 check King to G6
and probably Rook G1 this is forcing
once again to bring this King to F5 King
Leonidas King Leonidas Rook to G1 King
F5 and this is close to be a Checkmate
let's see if Wesley saw can finish the
game it's never easy against Magnus
Calon he's got 1,000 lives so uh Queen
H7 forcing Rook G6 otherwise Rook on G8
was uh falling and now Queen D7 very
very precise move first in Bishop B6
otherwise the bishop on D5 was hanging
and queen to B7 Rook h8 so let's
this position Wesley has one queen and a
pawn against uh a rook and a bishop but
more important look at the pawn
structure you know the black spone
structure look like the Philippines so
many islands right and Wesley so knows
how to deal uh with Philippines right
because he's originally from there he
was born in Philippines and then he
moved to the US so the problems with
this Pawn structure is that of course
you know uh it is extremely weak uh
pawns uh doesn't support don't support
each other other so it's very easy to
Target those pawns you know the only
contemplate that Magnus has is the H3
points that's why Wesley saw protects it
by playing King G3 and Magnus goes G5
maybe giving this Square for The Rook on
H4 now which is covered by the point on
G5 but of course you know a player like
Wesley so should win 100% of these games
again even Magnus skon Queen G7
targeting The Rook on h8 and if you want
to keep the Rook on H5 you either have
to go to H5 or H4 Rook H4 from Magnus
cson on B3 such a technical move
stopping C4 and then A4 fixing the
weaknesses on A5 on C5 sorry and on C5
and now the queen is going to graft all
those weaknesses you know of course you
got some Queen f8 ideas followed by
Queen C5 and magnos only has one Target
in this position which is the H3 Pawn
but he cannot move the king
right you have no mes with the king so
that means the bishop cannot put
pressure against the H3 Pawn so Magnus
tries to activate Rook by playing E4
well Wesley thinking about taking this
Pawn on e4 of course E3 could be an
option for black trying to promote that
pawn of course this is very far from
reality but you know Magnus grat TR you
know we've seen Magnus you know ER
winning some games where he was
completely lost so of course it's never
easy against the number one in the
wall he takes an E4 and now Magnus takes
uh with a king queen to G6 this forces
black to go basically uh back with the
king or to play Bishop F5 in order to
cover the bishop Queen C6 check now King
to D4 and Wesley plays C3 is such a
beautiful move if you take that pawn
then Queen C5 uh wins material so Queen
C5 Ken F6 and now you got a queen and
two pawns versus uh a rook and a bishop
once again the only counter play is uh
the pawn on H3 so Queen to B6 check now
Bishop E6 and uh it's not easy to
protect the pawn on H3 so let's see how
uh Wesley deals with that he plays King
to G2 such an elegant move guys if Rook
takes H3 then Queen E6 just wins the the
pawn End Game King E6 King H3 and then
you play B4 you have two pass pawns and
then the position is completely won
Magnus trying to fight playing Rook E4
now but of course you can start pushing
the pawns on the queen side I don't like
to take the pawn on A5 because that
allows Bishop to B3 and then we won't
have connected pass pawns anymore so
that's why Wesley decides to play B4
this is uh uh well a better move in my
opinion Wesley has a lot of technique
and now these pawns are ready to be
pushed Rook A2 and of course you can
play A5 Black's idea is to play Rook A3
followed by well by taking on H3 Queen
D4 check King F5 and now some more
checks on the
board King
E5 A5 finally pushing you know look at
the queen on D3 who stops Rook A3 Wesley
soy is playing such a strong
prophylactic uh game as well right this
this moves stopping all kind of
counterplay from the black side and now
after Bishop D5 Queen E3 King F5 it's
time to push right at some point so we
need to push the pawn to A6 if we want
to finish the game well Wesley has to be
careful because Rook G2 is m in this
moment so we got to be extremely careful
Rook G2 is made Magnus intending the
last trap the last trick so how uh to
run away from that Checkmate net he goes
King G4 now he finds a way uh along the
H5 square and after Rook G2 well King H5
Bishop E4 and now well some check on C3
probably is just a good move in know
that to proceed with A6 and there we go
and white is very close to promote the a
pawn and Magnus is about to resign with
only 40 seconds in the clock Rooks here
to and uh well Magnus resigns what a
game from Wesley so what a sacrifice
with Knight G4 with Knight G5 sorry what
a move E5 five in order to proceed with
Knight E4 and what a move Rook takes F6
this is chess this is the most exciting
sport in the world who says chess is
boring this been a pleasure this has
been grandm pep for chess.com big hacks
from Granada
Spain